it is the world famous friday mailbag if
you have anything you want to say to me
say it you can email info
davidpakman.com don't abuse it if you
send emails regularly you've probably
been flagged and filtered right into the
trash unfortunately there are people who
send us dozens of emails a day even five
a day uh we just can't we just can't
handle it we have too many too many
emails coming in um
if you're if you're abusing it
unfortunately it's getting filtered my
friends but let's get into some of the
messages that we did get brian wrote in
about an inaccuracy in a video
david your recent video confidence in
trump-filled supreme court collapses has
an inaccuracy chief justice roberts took
the bench on september 29 2005. this was
after the re-election of bush where he
did win the popular vote against kerry
by approximately 3 million votes the
same can be said about justice alito
um
going on to say who assumed the bench in
2006. while i understand what you're
saying about the 2000 popular vote count
the claim you made is partial partially
inaccurate and requires
further context yeah so the my point was
had bush had the first election gone by
the popular vote
bush never would have been president and
so yes this is true that there was
another election which bush did win but
bush never would have been in the
position of being re-elected
had it not been for the electoral rather
than popular vote results in the year
2000. next email is from marco
suggestion for one and a half million
subscribers
marco says i know you're going to reach
that milestone quite strongly
as an act of powerful celebration i
think you should shave your head when
you reach that goal
yeah like i honestly i would be willing
to do that when we get to 1.5 million
subscribers but not just because we get
there like we'll get there eventually
the question is is there anything we can
do to get there much more quickly
and i don't know that promising to shave
my head is actually going to do it
one other uh idea that came in from
maurice was david on achieving 1.5
million subscribers subscribers may i
suggest you do a live colonoscopy on air
now what's funny about that is
in general when we say doing a
colonoscopy we mean the doctor does it
the patient receives it so i'm gonna
guess maurice thinks i should receive a
colonoscopy on air
but what he's actually saying is i
should perform one and i my specialty is
podiatry i could not possibly do a
colonoscopy that would be outside
of my area of expertise but
it's an interesting idea nonetheless
the audience must be very confident
in me to suggest that
ryan wrote in about 2 000 mules and says
david do you plan on watching or
commenting on dinesh d'souza's 2000
mules my right wing co-workers have been
talking about it and i'm looking forward
to you dismantling the claims made in
the film
ryan
has actually been leaving dozens of
youtube comments saying the same thing
ryan's obsessed with the film so i
watched the sub the quote substantive to
the first two thirds of the film
it's nonsense there there's really
nothing to refute the whole concept of
the film is that using cell phone uh
locate geolocation data
which is not that accurate they pretend
it's accurate accurate and extrapolate
from that
that there were people
trafficking massive dumps of ballots
illegally
on election day in 2020.
there's there's no actual evidence
presented it's worthless don't waste
your time it'll it'll really rot your
brain
um so no we are not going to be
we are not going to be talking too much
more about that um next my pronunciation
of bangor maine sabrina from ellsworth
maine wrote in
and said
there's no er it's or i i pronounce that
banger and sabrina says it's bangor
i actually you know 99 of the time my
mispronunciations on this show are
purposeful you know dan bongino
tulsi gabbard
etc
i i actually didn't remember how to
pronounce bangor i thought it might have
been banger
i apologize to anyone who was offended
thank you sabrina
douglas wrote in and says argument for
prosecuting out of state abortions could
states that want to prosecute its
citizens for out-of-state abortions try
to argue that it's the same as if
california made murder legal and someone
took their child to california murdered
the child and then came back to their
home state well
you could argue that but
generally speaking states can only
prosecute crimes committed in their
jurisdiction in their jurisdiction so
if murder were legal in california
generally speaking if you take your kid
to california and kill them where it's
legal and then you go back to wherever
nebraska where it's illegal
nebraska can't prosecute you for a crime
that happened outside of its
jurisdiction so it's an interesting
question
it just doesn't work the way i think
douglas you may think it does
it's also kind of it's a very depressing
example i should say
um
catherine wrote in is miscarriage
manslaughter then david if fetuses have
rights then doesn't it follow that they
have rights to due process
it would be incredibly evil but any
miscarriage ought to be investigated on
the behalf of the miscarried fetus did
would-be mama miss her vitamins did she
travel against doctors advice did
would-be papa slam on the brakes while
speeding causing mama seat belt trauma
most miscarriages can in many cases be
shown to be a parent legally at fault if
the fetus has a right to life and due
process in the case of death
incredibly evil
but it's exactly what they're arguing
for isn't it katherine in in many cases
in many senses it is
in many senses it is and
listen we played a clip on our monday
show from someone that luke beasley
interviewed at the trump event over the
weekend
who said mothers who get an abortion
should get the death penalty they they
believe
uh abortion is murder
the mother is the murderer in texas they
have the death penalty so that's it
murder you know put put to death the
mother and unfortunately um these are
exactly the types of things i mean
listen last week we played a clip about
right-wingers expecting to start to see
uh the death penalty for abortion
providers as well
so that's exactly what they're pointing
to and it's quite horrifying
next email is from christopher
christopher says
you are unapologetically using the tools
you decry
david many of us are aware you're
employing the slippery slope in your row
coverage and yet some two months ago
you expose the slippery slope for what
it is a fallacy here's a link to that
video for reference what's up with that
chris the fallacy
is wrongly talking about a slippery
slope in the same way that appeal to
authority
isn't a fallacy if we're actually
dealing with an authority in the subject
matter
the fact that the slippery slope fallacy
exists doesn't make it fallacious when
it's accurate and within days of the
leaked roe v wade ruling you had
all sorts of anti-choice activists
talking about we've got to start
prosecuting the moms and we've got to
prosecute the abortion doctors
greg abbott in texas saying we've got to
reverse the supreme court decision that
allows the children of undocumented
immigrants to go to public school they
want to do away with that because listen
if you can do away roe v wade you can do
away with that
they're again talking about gay marriage
and saying gay marriage was just as
wrongly decided uh
we
there we've now had a dozen examples so
the slippery slope is not a fallacy
when it's happening
when it's happening and it is already
uh a user named truth and more truth
wrote on youtube i just don't get how
someone like alex jones has any
supporters how who is this stupid wwe
actors are more believable he admitted
it's all an act in court he could be
wearing a shirt that says i'm fake i'm
using you you're stupid if you believe
me
and people will still follow him
that's absolutely true
that's and we see that with a lot of the
trump-ist type cult
where it's
they could they could just lie
i'm sorry they could tell the truth
exposing that it's all a grift
and they would still have followers and
you know how they would rationalize it
they would go
alex jones had to say that in court
he's not really playing a character
he had to say it in court because
otherwise they were going to get him but
he really believes the stuff he says now
i don't actually know
alex jones may well believe the things
he said i've gone back and forth over
the years about
which it is brian wrote in about me
this loser is still on youtube this
channel is trash
david pakman has an iq of a tennis ball
but that would be an insult to the ball
itself your channel sucks david pakman
sucks
he doesn't covered anything realistic
this show is all bs all day every day
just like david pakman face is and then
i think that's the vomit emoji brian
remember
you don't have to watch this show it's
optional
it's optional you don't have to be here
my recommendation continues to be
if you don't like the show
don't watch the show i know it's a novel
thing and also by the way
you don't have to comment about
everything i say
like you don't have to email me
because i said something you disagree
with you could just go
oh yeah i disagree with that
i'm gonna get back to work
or whatever the case may be it's an
option it's an option it is available to
you we have a great bonus show for you
today sign up at joinpacman.com speaking
of alex jones
jones would tell you not to get the
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money everybody else that
makes money to find themselves is bad he
doesn't like it but i do and so i
encourage you to sign up at
joinpackman.com
get the bonus show we'll see you then